bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de ce sujet un peu différente ce qu'on
abhorre d'habitude on va parler de
l'avenir de la playstation 5 des rumeurs
de ce qu'on sait de la date de sortie du
prix enfin démarrer une autre chose et
ça on va le faire douter
[Musique]
la xbox live mix est sorti l'année
dernière l'année d'avant c'était le tour
de la ps4 6 mai la ps4 trop du coup on
peut se demander quand va arriver la
playstation 5
on voit très bien qu'il ya une recherche
de puissance la 4k qui arrive qui en
train vraiment de se positionner dans
tous les foyers donc à quel moment va
arriver cette playstation 5 avec de la
4k avec beaucoup de nouvelles
technologies quand est ce que sony vend
reprendre le lead et re devenir le
champion international avant la console
la plus puissante du monde
justement c'est ce qu'on va essayer voit
dans cette vidéo on a des infos des
rumeurs des tendances qui nous viennent
de damian song d'aniane tongs
excusez moi pour l'accent a trop comment
ça se prononce il est analyste chez
macquarie capital securities
et justement il a fait des analyses qui
est très intéressante une pense que sony
pourrait sortir sa playstation 5 cette
année au deuxième semestre 2018 quand on
regarde les dates de sortie des modèles
antérieurs c'est vrai que ça coule
presque sous le sens en faire un tour un
peu sur l'historique j'ai prévenu ma
petite fiche comme d'hab à l'origine
potasser mon sujet peu importe la
playstation est sorti en europe à
pareille date de sortie en europe
en 1995 la playstation 2 et la
playstation 2 excusez moi est arrivé en
2000 soit cinq ans après bon jusque là
mes calculs sont assez faciles ensuite
la playstation 3 en 2007
il aura fallu effectivement sept ans
entre la numéro deux et la numéro 3 la
ps4 est sortie en 2013 soit cinq ans
après effectivement la ps3 on parle pas
de la ps4 sliimy la ps4 pro qui seraient
des consoles demi génération donc si on
part vraiment de la ps4 et qu'on calcule
cinq ans jusqu'à la ps -cinq 2013 plus
cinq ans a fait 2018
donc on voit que si sony respecte le
calendrier qu'il a suivi
règle générale sur les générations
précédentes cette ps 5 pour arriver
cette année
d'ailleurs microsoft annonce en ce début
d'année que la xbox live mix a été la
console la plus vendue aux états unis
durant les fêtes de fin d'année est
également que la xbox ou ânesse a eu
d'excellentes ventes qui vont continuer
v pour intéresser davantage les hardcore
gamers qui veulent des expériences 4k
immersive et construire un abonnement
large avec le game passe et à étendre
leurs services
donc la xbox aux knicks seraient
effectivement leader en fin 2017 sur le
marché américain
sony doit réagir avec un produit plus
puissant pour redevenir le champion
incontesté avec la console la plus
puissante au monde alors on va très bien
que c'est une course à l'échalote
effectivement entre d'un côté microsoft
de l'autre côté sony qui pas après pas
console après console se bagarrent la
console la plus puissante au monde alors
de toute façon on sait très bien qu'au
final il n'y en aura aucun qui aura la
console la plus puissante au monde c'est
juste une question de capture à un
instant t
pour l'instant c'est microsoft sony va
reprendre le dessus notamment sur le
marché américain qui effectivement un
très gros marché
bon comme je vous le disais cette
console pourrait sortir au deuxième
semestre 2018 mais c'était sans compter
sur les prédictions d'un autre analyste
qui s'appelle michael pachter qui lui la
voix plutôt arriver en 2019 et peut-être
en 2020 alors michael pachter travail
chez wedbush securities
il pense que sony va attendre que les
foyers soient davantage équipés de
téléviseur 4k pour arriver avec une
console 4k donc au final est-ce qu'on
doit prendre ces rumeurs au sérieux oui
ou non dans le cadre damian sont gris
j'ai plutôt tendance à dire oui parce
qu'il avait effectivement prévu
l'arrivée de la ps4 pro et de la psp
slim
donc il ya des infos il a une vision et
analyse très bien marché ce qu'ils au
final pour être plutôt un signe positif
pour nous alors pourquoi est ce que sony
ne fait aucune annonce en fait c'est
très simple pour l'instant la ps 5 n'est
pas encore prête et ne va pas encore
être lancées immédiatement tout de suite
sur le marché donc ça serait dommage de
dire on va vous sortir des six sept huit
mois à la fin de l'année une pèse 5 du
coup c'est plus à peine d'acheter la ps4
pro ou la ps4 slim puisque d'ici
quelques mois pour sensiblement le même
budget vous allez retrouver une nouvelle
console ça serait se tirer une balle
dans le pied est très clairement les
ventes des autres consoles
dégringolerait pour l'instant sony joue
la prudence à temps pour l'annoncé
officielle probablement ils la
présenteront soit cet été soit en
septembre 2018 alors qu'est ce que cette
console pour avoir dans le ventre
moi ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on
regarde un petit peu ce qu'est la xbox
live mix tout de suite qui est pour
l'instant la console la plus puissante
au monde et ensuite on va imaginer que
de toute façon point par point la ps 5
sera plus puissante la xbox phoenix à un
processeur amd
huit coeurs x86 cadencés à 2 3 ghz une
puce graphique amd 40 coeur radio am et
172 beggars 12 giga de ram gddr5 6
téraflops de puissance une bande
passante mémoire de 320 6 gigaoctets par
seconde 1 téraoctets de stockage un
lecteur blu-ray 4k uhd et tout ça pour
le prix de 499 euros
on peut toujours spéculer sur la fiche
technique de la ps5 ça serait
effectivement donné des fiv pour donner
des chiffres
ce qui est sûr c'est que là où il a xbox
aux knicks à 12 giga de ram
on peut très bien imaginer que la ps1
qu'on aura 16 voire carrément un peu
plus le processeur la carte graphique le
stockage tout ça sera augmentée ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'on retrouvera de lavery
quatre cas au minimum à 60 images par
seconde quel sera le prix de cette
console
j'imagine très clairement une console
aux alentours des 500 euros aux
alentours 500 550 600 euros on va pas
s'affoler c'est vrai que le prier quand
même élevé c'est vrai que ça fait un
budget derrière de la recherche et
développement et à l'innovation et on
voit très bien que ses consoles on va
les renouveler quoi aller tous les trois
quatre cinq ans on n'est pas si vous
voulez comme les smartphones ou les prix
augmentent énormément on est aujourd'hui
sur des paniers de l'ordre de 500 600
700 800 euros voire même plus si
affinités et des produits qu'on va
changer en moyenne tous les deux ans une
console elle va coûter moins cher à
l'achat et vous la changerait moins
longtemps
donc ça paraît pas complètement
déconnant d'ailleurs dites moi ce que
vous en pensez et votre habit sony
proposera cette playstation 5 à quel
prix et justement avec cette playstation
5 on s'attend à voir un nouveau casque
de réalité virtuelle j'espère avoir un
casque de vr en 4 qui a de meilleurs
contrôles heures une meilleure
expérience de jeu toujours des jeux plus
immersif des choses encore plus dingue
pour avoir joué plusieurs fois en verre
sans la playstation 4 pro je trouve que
l'expérience a juste bluffante
alors le catalogue de jeux maintenant il
est complètement obligatoire que sony
fasse une rétrocompatibilité avec tous
les jeux l'ensemble du catalogue de la
ps4 ps4 au ps kathleen ps4 on n'imagine
pas du tout à un moment que sony puisse
sortir une pèse 5 avec uniquement
quelques jeux au catalogue et des petits
jeux qui vont arriver par ci par là même
si effectivement on sait que derrière
beaucoup de développeurs il ya beaucoup
d'éditeurs venir beaucoup de titres qui
vont sortir pour cette ps5
avec de la 4k mai
obligatoire qu'il y ait une
rétrocompatibilité si vous êtes déjà
client voulait garder vos jeux vous
voulez jouer sur votre nouvelle console
de jeu vous allez aimer et en plus de ça
si vous êtes un nouveau client
si vous venez par exemple de microsoft
il venait de nintendo ou alors si vous
êtes vraiment quelqu'un qui arrive dans
l'univers du jeu vidéo et bien vous
voulez pouvoir avoir effectivement un
catalogue très large
donc ça paraît complètement logique que
sony propose une rétrocompatibilité sur
tout le catalogue de la ps4
sinon je comprends plus rien il devrait
faire comme microsoft à aller sur cette
nouvelle tendance des jeux
dématérialisés
c'est à dire proposer un catalogue en
ligne vous passeriez le console vous
pourriez jouer à vos jeux sur tous vos
device que ce soit voté les votre
ordinateur votre smartphone ou votre
tablette la puissance de calcul se
ferait directement chez sony et vous
vous aurez juste besoin d'une bande
passante pour pouvoir en profiter
d'ailleurs j'ai déjà rencontré une
société française qui s'appelle black
note qui développe cette solution qui en
gros le net flics du jeu vidéo
d'ailleurs je vous invite à aller voir
cette vidéo donc on va très bien au
travers de ses différentes tendances
travers ses différentes rumeurs de
toutes ces informations le
positionnement stratégique de sony quoi
qu'il en soit on est sur cette console
va arriver assez rapidement même si
c'est pas fin 2018 sera très
probablement l'année prochaine
en tout cas 2018 ça me paraît vraiment
logique dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous pensez que cette
ps 5 va arriver rapidement
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
personne va mettre une grosse gifle à la
xbox mannix il va réécrire un petit peu
l'histoire du jeux vidéos en 4k
je sais que vous êtes très nombreux à
être passionné par sa j'ai déjà vu
d'ailleurs tous vos commentaires sont
mes précédentes vidéos sur la xbox aux
knicks sur la vidéo que j'ai fait
d'ailleurs xbox one-x veris ps4 pro
assez difficile à prononcer donc
j'attends tout vos commentaires pouvoir
les lieux pouvoir aussi ont discuté avec
vous est-ce que vous pensez que cette ps
5 va arriver cette année et qu'elle va
devenir la console la plus puissante au
monde
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
je vous invite comme d'habitude a blessé
des jolies pousse à vous abonner à
activer la cloche lorsqu'on va parler
toujours plus toujours mieux d'altec des
produits d' influence des produits qui
vont rentrer chez nous et croyez moi y
en a de plus en plus qui vont arriver
donc je vous invite à faire une seule
chose à rester connectés d'ici là quand
êtes-vous bien soyez sages
je vous embrasse et à très bientôt
[Musique]